[Musique]
une plante d'anticorps 78 visant Sidi
Elmer l'association anticorruption
reproche à l'ancien maire par intérim de
Mantes-la-Jolie un conflit d'intérêt
dans le prolongement d'une convention
d'occupation d'un local municipal à
titre gratuit d'une association les
faits alors que l'échéance n'était pas
encore arrivé et que sidyl est mort et
le directeur général de cette
association un second document concerne
le bail professionnel au bénéfice d'une
entreprise dirigée par son frère les
plaintes n'ont pour le moment pas donné
lieu à l'ouverture d'une procédure
judiciaire un coup de projecteur sur
leur carrière à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes
plusieurs personnalités masculines du
monde de la technologie donne le temps
d'une journée de leur compte à une femme
certains eviloy y participent la raison
les femmes sont cinq fois moins
nombreuses dans ce secteur et moins
visible sur la plateforme que leurs
homologues masculins c'est une maladie
qui touche une femme sur dix
l'endométriose elle est devenue sujet
d'une stratégie nationale en janvier
2022 avec la création par l'Agence
régionale de santé Île-de-France de
quatre filières dans les Yvelines à les
pilotées par les centres hospitaliers de
Versailles et de Poissy Saint-Germain la
filière se nomme voyelle et a été
officiellement lancée hier mardi 7 mars
et à voyelles couvre le 78 et le 95
Ouest
et donc a pour mission de permettre à
toutes les femmes qui présentent de
l'endométriose d'avoir un diagnostic
précoce et une prise en charge adaptée
graduée en fonction de sa situation à
partir du médecin généraliste de la
sage-femme libérale du gynécologue de
ville mais aussi d'autres professionnels
qui vont pouvoir et les aider les
soulager que peuvent être déclinés des
ostéopathes etc la consultation
gynécologique peut permettre d'évoquer
le diagnostic c'est ce qui a été
notifié par la Haute Autorité de Santé
en 2017 dans les recommandations qui
fallait avoir un interrogatoire à ces
standardisés et aussi dans la mesure du
possible un examen gynécologique un
examen pelvien qui est qui permet de
détecter des signes la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites
continuent ce mercredi 8 mars notamment
les transports étaient à nouveau
perturbés une troisième journée de grève
d'affilée ce profil jeudi 9 mars et
l'intersydical annonçait deux nouvelles
journées le samedi 11 mars et le 14 ou
le 15 mars
[Musique]